let's figure out that must mean that
underneath it is this this and this
that's not how this was built this was
given this
you know very simple framework
what consequences does it have
now is it going to intersect with actual
physics or did we just miss completely
and is this a model of nothing in
particular
the you know it's very important that
you build up from the simple model
and then you see where you build and it
so happens that the amazing thing that
was really the big surprise of a year
and a bit ago is you know the thing we
built
is physics basically and that's the
thing that was that was sort of the big
surprise it might not have been you know
as it's turning out okay i now realize
and i should that i should have realized
years ago
that it's sort of inevitable that this
has to be physics
but that wasn't obvious to me as we were
building it and it's it's the thing
that's been really interesting to me is
the realization that not only is it a
model of physics
it's also a model of a whole bunch of
other things
and
that
you know i had the experience with
cellular automata that i worked on for
many years so cellular automata are just
these extremely simple programs where
you just have a line of cells let's say
each one is either black or white and
then a series of steps you update the
color of a cell according to the color
of the cell above it and to its left and
right let's say you might have thought
that
a simple rule like that would always
lead to simple patterns of behavior but
the big discovery that i made in the
early 1980s is that that's not true that
you can get very complicated behavior
even from very simple rules
and the thing that happened with
cellular automata is they're very
minimal models they're just you have a
line of cells or you have a
a array of cells or whatever and you're
applying these local rules and you're
updating the thing very minimal model so
then you roll the clock forward a few
decades and you realize oh gosh there
are models that use cellular automata
for zillions of different things from
you know road traffic flow to you know
the way leaves work to the way that um i
don't know catalysts and and cam and
surfaces work to the way all kinds of
different things all kinds of to mollusk
pigmentation patterns whatever all kinds
of different things and so in a sense
you have this very minimal model which
in that particular case assumes a
certain structure of space and time but
you have a very minimal model and that
model ends up being a model of lots of
kinds of things so in a sense it's
unsurprising that this much more
flexible model that we have that we
built for physics
ends up looking like it's going to be a
really
i mean
you know very powerful model for the
foundations of a whole bunch of other
fields as well
and the thing that's really interesting
about that is you know so i've been
doing a whole bunch of work on meta
mathematics the kind of overall
structure of mathematics where where the
nodes are not atoms of space but the
nodes are mathematical theorems and the
relationships between them are proofs of
one theorem from another well you might
say what is what on earth does that have
to do with the structure of the physical
universe
but it turns out that it looks like the
the formalistic structure of that is the
same as the structure of the physical
universe and that's um that's something
that's uh both uh it's it's a it's both
surprising and the most important thing
for me is it means that you get to have
this kind of cross-connection of the
ideas from metamathematics and the ideas
from physics so in physics we've learned
a lot of stuff about how general
relativity works how all these kinds of
things work so now we get to import
those ideas into meta mathematics and we
get to import the ideas of mathematical
logic into physics and so by realizing
that the underlying formalism is the
same we get to make that kind of uh
conversion and this formalism also seems
to be
uh really the right formalism to think
about distributed computing
it may very well be the right formalism
to think about systems biology
and it uh the the one that i've been
poking at a lot recently is is economics
and it may well be the right formalism
to think about that in each of these
applications the details of of what the
corresponding what the thing that's like
the atoms of space says are different
and the details of how it works is
different but the point is that the
overall structure the overall formalism
seems to carry over and that allows you
to use sort of big ideas from one field
in another field so that's that's been
you know it's it's a it's a more global
theory than i ever imagined it could
possibly be and and i've realized that
um the you know the fundamental uh sort
of struggle in a sense for these
theories is the following you have a
simple rule underneath
but that simple rule just like in my
cellular automata um the simple rule
leads to very complicated behavior but
it leads to behavior that is
computationally irreducible in the sense
it's complicated enough you can't tell
what's going to happen without basically
just running the rule and seeing what
happens